muchas gracias soy orgullosamente
potosino
las ciudades nuestras ciudades
esto es lo que quisiera reflexionar un
momento con ustedes el día de hoy
nuestras ciudades nos impulsan
en
este es probablemente un dato que ya
hemos visto y que algunos de ustedes ya
han visto pero quisiera que lo tomáramos
como base para profundizar un poquito
más sobre este tema el 50 55 por ciento
de la población mundial ya vive en
ciudades en nuestro país cerca del 80%
de los mexicanos
en zonas urbanas
es decir en méxico prácticamente la
totalidad de la población en los
próximos diez años se estima en los
próximos años que el 90% los mexicanos
vivamos en ciudades 13 millones de
personas en los próximos 10 años en
nuestro país van a ocupar nuestras
ciudades
entonces reflexionemos en la ciudad como
la plataforma de desarrollo
nosotros como individuos pero para
nosotros como comunidad
y entonces entender a la ciudad como
esta plataforma
nos debe de llevar a otra reflexión
entonces como debemos diseñar nuestras
ciudades
como debemos planear nuestras ciudades
como debemos gestionarlas para que
realmente sean plataformas de desarrollo
y no inhibidores de desarrollo yo creo
que todos en nuestra mente y en nuestros
viajes de nuestras visitas podemos
identificarnos con aquellas ciudades que
nos parecen atractivas agradables que
nos invitan a visitar las que cuando
estamos ahí nos sentimos contentos
energizados pero también estoy seguro
que nuestra mente o en nuestras visitas
hemos identificado ciudades que no son
así que nos transmiten desorganización
descontrol
ineficiencia desorden
entonces hay diferentes maneras de hacer
ciudad
hay diferentes maneras en que las
ciudades nos habilitan para ser mejores
sociedades y de eso es lo que quisiera
reflexionar con ustedes y en particular
reflexionar de nuestras ciudades
mexicanas
si las ponemos en este espectro de si
nuestras ciudades en méxico nos están
ayudando a ser una mejor sociedad o
vamos en sentido contrario reflexionemos
un poco
ustedes ven que nuestras ciudades están
evolucionando para ser plataformas que
nos unan que nos permitan convivir mejor
que nos den condiciones de seguridad
de justicia que permitan desarrollarnos
de manera equilibrada sostenible
sustentable
vamos en la dirección correcta en méxico
con nuestras ciudades
pues esa es parte de lo que tenemos que
respondernos
ninguna ciudad por bella por atractivas
por
hermosa que nos parezca esté exenta de
problemas la ciudad y sobre todo la
concentración de personas en las
ciudades ha generado grandes
oportunidades para todos pero también
grandes retos para todos
y el tema es estamos capacitados para
enfrentar esos retos tenemos las
herramientas tenemos la conciencia para
enfrentar estos retos y entonces si
aprovechar en su máxima capacidad las
oportunidades que nos ofrecen las
ciudades pues eso es lo que trataremos
de ayudar a responder al menos desde mi
punto de vista en esta sesión
y déjenme tomar un concepto como base un
concepto de un economista urbano
de la universidad de harvard que se
llama edward kleiser que tiene un libro
maravilloso que se llama el triunfo de
las ciudades y él hace el planteo un
concepto de la ciudad que me parece muy
poderoso dice las ciudades son la
ausencia de espacio físico entre las
personas y las empresas son proximidad
de densidad cercanía nos permiten
trabajar
y jugar juntos y su éxito depende de la
facilidad de la conexión física
las ciudades son la ausencia de espacio
físico entre las personas su éxito
depende de la facilidad de la conexión
física entonces tengamos esto en mente
porque ahorita vamos a ver algunos datos
sobre las ciudades mexicanas para
reflexionar si vamos caminando en esta
dirección o vamos caminando en sentido
contrario
entonces miren hay una información muy
valiosa que se generó en el gobierno
federal haciendo un análisis que había
pasado en las ciudades mexicanas de 1980
al 2010 tomando descenso ascenso en 1980
y 2010 y el dato arroja que la población
urbana en mexico se duplicó pero el
espacio urbano el territorio que ocupan
nuestras ciudades se multiplicó por 7
ok hay dos veces más personas viviendo
en las ciudades en el 2010 que 1980 pero
nuestras ciudades son siete veces más
grandes
necesitamos un espacio siete veces más
grande sería la primera pregunta
es necesario tener siete veces más
espacio para esto profundicemos un
poquito más esta es una imagen de la
zona metropolitana de monterrey donde se
ve
se puede visualizar cómo va expandiendo
la mancha urbana
y nos podemos preguntar este es un
crecimiento planeado esto es algo que en
1980 1970 planeamos dijimos así va a
crecer la ciudad
nos está pasando
la ciudad monterrey duplicó así
similarmente al promedio nacional su
población urbana también de menos hecho
en 2010 pero multiplicó por 5 su mancha
urbana un poquito menos que el promedio
nacional
todo este espacio
se recuerden a glazer la ciudad son
proximidad cercanía
parece ser que estamos yendo en sentido
contrario
sanluis sanluis es perfecto no no no no
tiene
ahorita vamos a san luis pero un poquito
monterrey bueno no es que este problema
de la expansión urbana sucede en todos
lados y es cierto pero hicimos un
análisis de ciudades similares a
monterrey similares en el número de
habitantes que tiene monterrey que son
alrededor de 4.6 millones de habitantes
es por ejemplo madrid tiene 5.3 millones
de habitantes ocupa el 80% del área que
ocupa monterrey belo horizonte en brasil
tiene 4 millones de habitantes y ocupa
el 62 por ciento del área que ocupa
monterrey guadalajara tiene 4.4 millones
de habitantes y tiene el 66 por ciento
de la mancha urbana que tiene monterrey
ahora qué pasa con ese espacio adicional
que estamos haciendo tenemos que
invertir en calles tenemos que invertir
en llevar iluminación energía eléctrica
agua drenajes espacio público de calidad
seguridad limpieza salud entretenimiento
educación cuando hacemos una ciudad más
grande la inversión que se requiere
primero para hacerla es mucho mayor pero
después para proveerle servicios de
calidad a los habitantes es mucho mayor
qué pasa si en lugar de haber invertido
miles de millones de dólares para
extender la ciudad hubiésemos invertido
sus recursos para proveer servicios de
calidad a los habitantes
esa es la pregunta y ese es el reto esta
expansión urbana nos está costando mucho
nos está generando problemas que ya
estamos empezando a vivir como cuales
nos está alejando de las zonas de
trabajo de las zonas de empleo de las
zonas de educación dependemos cada día
más del automóvil o del transporte
motorizado que el efecto lo estamos
viendo en nuestro aire la calidad de los
servicios públicos va en decadencia hay
una serie de efectos hay una
desintegración de la sociedad no porque
nos estamos alejando hay una serie de
efectos que nos están afectando nuestra
calidad de vida por este fenómeno san
luís potosí
efectivamente la población en salud se
duplicó por la mancha urbana se
multiplicó por 7
en 1980 san luís potosí a tener 470 mil
habitantes y ocupaba una huella de 2.000
hectáreas
en el 2010 están en sus cuadros en rojo
tenía un millón de habitantes un millón
cuarenta habitantes pero ocupa 14.000
hectáreas la verdad
la inversión que se requiere para esto
la necesidad de llevar servicios a esta
expansión urbana es lo que tenemos que
hacer en méxico
a costa de qué está pasando esto de
muchas cosas pero entre uno de los
factores es el abandono de los centros
urbanos esta es unas fotos del barrio de
san sebastián en san luís potosí
entonces esta expansión de las ciudades
esta inversión para llevar las ciudades
afuera nos deja los centros vacíos
los barrios originales de san luís
potosí han perdido el 30% de la
población en los últimos 20 años han
dejado de vivir en el centro de la
ciudad 30 mil habitantes en los últimos
20 años
y qué condiciones
se encuentra se están perdiendo
es la dirección correcta que debemos de
tomar en nuestras ciudades en méxico
estamos haciendo lo correcto podemos
permitir que esta tendencia desordenada
no planeada no prevista la expansión
urbana sigue generando costos presentes
pero sobre todo futuros que no vamos a
poder cubrir la respuesta que yo tengo
es no no podemos seguir permitiendo que
esto siga sucediendo hay muchas cosas
por hacer hay muchas cosas por dejar de
hacer la ciudad es un sistema complejo
que no podemos resolver de manera
sencilla pero si hay una invitación que
quiero hacerles a todos ustedes porque
debemos todos de asumir una
responsabilidad sobre la ciudad
no es un tema que podamos delegarle a
los gobiernos es un tema que nos
corresponde a todos ciudadanos
instituciones universidades
obviamente autoridades resolver pero no
podemos delegar selo a los gobiernos es
demasiado importante para dejárselo a
ellos resolverlo esto necesitamos
recuperar y mi propuesta a todos es
recuperemos los centros de nuestras
ciudades
en los centros de la sociedad esa
infraestructura en los centros
necesidades hay hospitales hay escuelas
que ya no tienen niños generalmente en
los centros de nuestras ciudades hay
parques están las alamedas pero ya no
viven personas en el centro de la ciudad
ahora no rescatemos los centros de las
ciudades con una visión
de una escenografía hueca vacía
probablemente bonita para el visitante o
para el turista pero vacía de vida de
energía de empleo
rescatemos los para que recuperen la
población para que la población quiera
vivir en el centro porque encuentra un
espacio para desarrollar su vida
afortunadamente hay ejemplos en el mundo
de que si se puede
pero vamos muy tarde
vamos muy tarde el centro de san luís
potosí se está perdiendo entonces la
invitación es a todos a recuperar y si
se puede tenemos que dejar de ver esta
imagen que estamos viendo como normal en
la ciudad para pensar que esta es la
ciudad que necesitamos es el mismo lugar
y que juntos trabajando para en lugar de
tener esto tener esto claro que podemos
y claro que un espacio de esta
naturaleza te invita a vivir te invita a
poner un negocio te invita a tener una
vida activa de ciudad tenemos que poder
pensar una ciudad que en lugar de tener
estos espacios exclusivos para los
automóviles tenemos espacios compartidos
para todos pero hoy no los tenemos hoy
no es así nuestra realidad tenemos que
pensar en que si podemos cambiar y hay
ejemplos en el mundo hay ejemplos en
méjico de que lo estamos haciendo pero
la invitación y la petición es que te
necesitamos hacerlo a mucho mayor
velocidad estamos perdiendo nuestras
ciudades estamos perdiendo nuestro
futuro recuperar nuestras ciudades
recuperar la concepción correcta de
hacer ciudad
recuperar nuestro futuro
si hay me parece una conducción una
condición que debemos buscar y esto jane
jacobs que fue una pensadora y una
activista sobre la ciudad no los decía
hace muchos años y esta es una
invitación a todos nosotros las ciudades
tienen la capacidad de proveer algo para
todos sí y sólo si son creadas por todos
entonces lo que invito es que asumamos
la responsabilidad no es un tema de los
gobiernos es un tema de todos nosotros
pero también los invito a actuar con un
sentido de urgencia no tenemos tiempo
que perder muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]